combination of linear Maps is defined on a given input is that we just take the same linear combination of the outputs
that might look sort of trivial but it makes sense the output we get from this hypothetical scenario is simply the
weighted average of the outputs we would get from the two original channels nevertheless this is a new channel and
if ph0 and 51 were indeed valid channels then for sure this new mapping will also be a valid Channel another way to say
that in mathematical terms is that the set of all channels from a given input system to a given output system is
convex and that's an important mathematical property of channels we can do this more generally if we have M channels 5 0 through f m minus one say
along with the probability vector that tells us what the probability is for each Channel then we get a new channel by averaging the channels accordingly so
in some sense this is an endless source of new channels for example the class of so-called mixed unitary channels is what
we get by taking convex combinations of unitary channels that is if we have M unitary matrices u0 through u m minus
one all having the same size along with the probability Vector then if we take the weighted average of the channels
corresponding to the individual unit matrices as is shown here on the screen then we'll get a channel and channels
that can be written like this are called mixed unary channels not every channel is a mixed unitary Channel we can't get
every channel this way but they do come up quite a lot next we'll look at a few specific
examples of channels these will all be examples of channels from one cubit to one cubit which are called Cubit
channels for short the first one is called the Cubit reset Channel and the idea is that this channel resets a cubit
to the zero State here we're using the capital Greek letter Lambda to denote this Channel and the way that you can remember what this channel does is to
think about the block sphere Capital Lambda kind of looks like an arrow pointing up and the zero state is at the top of the block sphere so it's as if
it's pointing to the location of the output the way it's defined in mathematical terms is that Lambda of row equals the trace of row time c0 bra 0 so
if we evaluate it on any density me Matrix row we'll get the zero State as a density matrix it's natural to wonder
why we need the trace couldn't we simply Define Lambda of row to be cat zero bra zero without the trace of row in front
and the answer to that question is no channels need to be linear maps and it wouldn't be linear if we removed the trace of row also keep in mind that
sometimes we need to know how a channel works as a linear mapping on non- density Matrix inputs for example as we
saw earlier if we want to know what a channel does when we apply it to a compound system system we need to
evaluate that channel on the individual blocks of a larger block Matrix and although the entire block Matrix may be
a density Matrix the individual blocks generally won't be so let's see exactly what this channel does when we apply it
to just one part of a compound system and more specifically what it does when we apply it to one of two cubits that
form an ebit to be precise suppose A and B are cubits that as a pair are in the five plus Bell State and we apply Lambda
to say the first Cubit a to figure out what happens let's first Express the five plus State as a density Matrix and
for the sake of this example let's use direct notation to do that here's the five plus State as a Quantum State vector and here's what we get when we
multiply this Vector to its conjugate transpose and expand it all out we can then apply the channel to the first Cubit and evaluate what we get here's
Lambda applied to the first Cubit and here's what we get when we evaluate each of the terms the trace of k0o br0 is one
and so is the trace of cat 1 bra 1 so in those two cases the output of the channel is cat 0 bra 0 and that explains
the two terms in the answer the trace of Kat zero bra one on the other hand is zero as is the trace of Kat 1 bra zero
and so those two terms evaluate to zero and therefore don't contribute anything to the answer we can now simplify a
little bit and what we obtain is the zero State for the first Cubit which is a and the completely mixed state for the
second Cubit which is B notice in particular that we did not get a plus state for B which wouldn't necessarily
have been a bad guess if we didn't know anything about density matrices and we just looked at the quantum State Vector representation of the state but that's
not how this channel works and there isn't any channel that could possibly work that way the channel Lambda is called the Cubit reset Channel but the
way it works is really more like throwing the input cubit in the trash and replacing it with a fresh cubit in the zero state but this in fact is the
only Cubit channel that always outputs the zero State here's another example of of a cubit Channel known as the
completely def phasing Channel this one is denoted by Delta and the way that it works is that it leaves the diagonal
entries of any 2x2 matrix alone and zeros out the off diagonal entries Delta is the Greek letter equivalent of D in
the Latin alphabet and that's short for diagonal so that's one way to remember what this channel does we can
alternatively Express this channel using direct notation as is shown on the screen and just to be clear the output
is always a 2X two Matrix so in particular the two zero outputs refer to the all zero 2x two Matrix we often do
this and we've seen this before in this series the symbol zero is generally used perhaps Ambiguously to mean the zero
element of whatever thing we're talking about whether it's scalers vectors matrices or whatever let's do the same thing that we did previously for the
Cubit reset Channel and see what happens if we apply this channel to half of an ebit the setup is the same so I won't go
through that part and the result is the state shown on on the screen which is essentially a shared random bit so what
this channel did was basically to convert an ebit into a perfectly correlated pair of classical random bits
and that's consistent with a more General interpretation of this channel by zeroing out the off diagonal inges of a density Matrix we're effectively
throwing away the quantum stuff in a density Matrix leaving a diagonal density Matrix that represents a
classical probabilistic State another way to think about this is that this channel represents a perfect noiseless classical channel that transmits a bit
so if we put a zero state or a one state or a convex combination of those two states into the channel then that state comes out unchanged but if you try to
put a Quantum State into it like a plus state for instance it's as if the channel measures that state with a standard basis measurement and then
transmits the classical result one final example of a cubit channel is the completely depolarizing Channel what
this channel does is to always output the completely mixed state so it's similar in some sense to the Cubit reset
Channel except that we get a rather less useful completely mixed state out rather than an initialized Cubit a natural way
to think about this channel is that it represents an extreme form of noise and as far as Cubit channels are concerned
it really doesn't get any noisier than this I don't have a good pneumonic to share for remembering what this one does other than to say that Omega is the last
letter of the Greek alphabet and it's sometimes associated with the end of all things and perhaps this is what happens